did you see the firestorm you lit on the
internet when you posted 2lw with natori
yes i hope it was like a good
inspirational firestorm you know
it got us so excited you know you don't
need me to tell you that 3lw is one of
the most beloved girl groups to ever
exist
how did that come about you and natalie
linking up well crazy enough she'd been
on the reel several times and i feel
like we never had animosity towards each
other in that way that it was just like
oh hi it's awkward because there's this
elephant in the room of all that we've
been through
um but it would be like oh hi and i
think there always was this
idea of like i'm happy for you and
you're happy for me this unspoken thing
but like we'd pretty much greet each
other and just go right into interviews
there was a lot that went on in that
time that now looking back is just like
it was so young and it was crazy yeah
and that i genuinely from the bottom of
my heart never meant any harm towards
you and i think you're talented and
beautiful and cute
and this last time
she was just like
we're almost 40 years old now like the
two of like that's just the reality of
it
and she found out that i was moving back
to new york and we were like let's we're
both in new york now like let's spend
some time together let's get together
let's have dinner and that's what that
was and she was like let's take a pic
and i was like yeah
even
the hashtag like let the healing begin i
think that that's key i think so many of
us
have had experiences in our lives where
we're just like wait what was that all
about and you let them go but at the
same time you almost want to revisit
them when you get older to actually be
like what was that about and how can we
move forward and i think that's where
we're at yeah i mean i i don't i don't
want to pry but the word healing makes
me wonder what are some of those things
that you and natori sit down at a dinner
table and talk about i think our youth
and our childhood and the experience of
being in 3lw for sure is something that
we both have had to heal individually
from and then come together and and and
heal what honestly was like a dope
beautiful friendship and rekindle that
and
there are things that her and i
will share forever that no one will ever
know or understand and that's just the
truth of it yeah that's that sisterhood
right yeah like i literally told her i
actually hit her up on her birthday a
little bit after um
and i was like happy birthday and she's
like oh my god you remember my birthday
and i was like of course uh absolutely
those things are ingrained in your head
because you spend so much like we lived
in bunk beds together we did life
together for so many years and my
husband's birthday is the 19th and hers
is the 20th and for the first few years
of me and my husband's marriage i'd be
like yeah because his birthday's on the
20th and you'd be like the 19th and i'm
like oh it's maturity's birthday that i
would get it confused she's like i know
your birthday yours is october 24th and
i'll never forget it wow so it's those
little things that i'm grateful for well
to see such a beautiful full circle
moment of you know the two of you as
teenagers making music
[Music]
the big question is is something
happening is there sort of a reunion
there is nothing set okay there is no
reunion set there's nothing like that
set up but i think the most important
thing is like
not not music but like the real life is
is good does that make sense totally
yeah i think i mean i would never say
never yeah but um and she's super
talented and has an incredible voice i
mean hello play is gonna play i will
stay true only to you
now that you said the healing is
happening with that healing i just was
curious is the door open for for
something to happen i don't think we
we'd ever say um
never to the two of us doing something
together but i don't know we shall see
yeah you envision it being more of a 2lw
kind of project i i just know that her
and i
we we absolutely get like there's
certain things you know when they don't
feel labored or forced yeah natural
literally us getting down and sitting
and having dinner was like
woosah easy all the good feels and it
was really special haven't seen you
since high school and yet it still feels
too soon welcome back baxter it's been
so fun watching you on raven's home
thank you you know i love raven we
always me and raven talk about you
you know we're like we love you what do
you say all this we love her
and um
she's just
she's just the real deal you know what i
mean like i'm sure good person
wise funny fun talented it was my first
time that i got to actually see her
direct and that was so inspiring i
literally
i kept saying to her she kept laughing
at me because she calls me chuchi she's
like chooch come i need you the cameras
are doing this and i'm watching her and
i'm like i can't mess up because i can't
let you down she's like you are not
letting me down but i was most nervous
for that episode because you know
i want to make her proud so it was like
super important um and it's just been so
much fun and i love love love doing that
show i love
seeing
the new talent and it's funny because
like they're fans of cheetah girls as
well they're like oh my god i get to
work with cheetah girl and i'm now
playing like their mom i know you know
so it's it's wild you know this
interview wouldn't be complete if i
didn't ask next year will mark 20 years
since the cheetah girls
have you had any conversations or would
you be open to doing something with all
the original cheetah girls back together
bubbles and chuchi forever we are down
we don't know what that would look like
maybe a reunion special like what
friends did you know that was so
gratifying to go back down the rabbit
hole and learn new things about that
experience it's my face going
i don't know
what do you think i would never say
never but at the same time i do think
some things are sacred and they're and
they're
sometimes more beautiful when they're
just left them up all around the world
[Music]
everyone wants to know is a solo adrian
project ever gonna be a possibility
again i feel like the more i do israel
and new breed the more i find my voice i
like to say that i am the perpetual girl
group member because i i actually do
love working in groups i there is
something i feed off of that energy of
us being able to come together and sing
so i feel like the more i do that the
more i do find my own voice
and
that's been really really special i can
assure you that yes there will be one
time frame i can't tell you
um we are building out a stunning studio
in the house i've obviously loved being
on the reel but there is something about
kind of being able to control my own
schedule now and deciding what do i want
to wake up and do i think i want to
record a song i can do that and i'm i'm
really excited about that right now
we're like gearing up we just did this
awesome thing called camp new breed with
israel a new breed yes which i love
israel is israel and i get to be a part
of new breed and we literally hosted
this incredible camp where everybody got
together and we're going to be putting
out an album live from camp new breed so
now we're preparing for the rollout of a
marketing plan and i've got my whole
team on this adobe acrobat like
template that i have where i'm like okay
so this is the rollout these are the
days that socials need to be delivered
like certain deliverables like you got
to have this for social media on this
day you got to post this this day and if
i get something done i get to check it
off can i just rewind for two seconds
yeah is it public knowledge do do your
fans know that you're dropping another
album no this is actually exclusive yeah
oh my there will be a live album
from camp new breed
it does have a name i'm gonna hold that
in
it's in worship anywhere i'll just say
it
i can't see what you do to me yes it is
called worship anywhere because
literally we were
we were in the forest worshiping down
the water we were down the water slide
praising the lord we were in the
cafeteria making drum beats on the table
we created something really really
special so me and my sister are singing
together on this project there are more
songs that i sing in spanish on here and
i just feel like this has been the
outlet where i feel comfortable singing
and it's like um it's been really
special
you